view of the challenges that the European  Union faces the importance of cohesion  policy becomes more pronounced the  council adopted conclusions on making  cohesion policy more effective more  relevant and more visible to our  citizens results also demonstrates that  1 million jobs were created through the  financial support to more than 120,000  startups and around 400,000 SMEs with  regards to the support for disaster hit  regions ministers welcomed council  agreement on the EU support for regions  said by floods earthquakes drafts and  also other natural disasters revision  will see now and increase an EU share of  the costs up to ninety percent I think  it's very important that all the  ministers agreed that cohesion policy  makes also a European economy stronger  and healthier and really contributed to  make every to improve every Europeans  quality of life and I think it is each  one of the best tool to counter  extremism and nationalism